dans une rue enneigée de kiev ce matin
quelques mots du président ukrainien à
hauteur d'homme comme à son habitude
voici le printemps il est triste comme
la guerre mais tout va bien nous les
vaincrons tous
mais un peu plus tôt c'est avec un tout
autre ton que vladimir et l'ins qui
interpellait les occidentaux
je la fêterais jour connaître mais
treize jours on nous dit que nous
livrera des avions
responsabilité mais aussi sur ceux
d'occident ou n'ont pas été capables de
prendre une décision dont les paroles
fortes d'un homme qui construit chaque
jour un peu plus sa stature
présidentielle
hier soir il se filmait pour la première
fois depuis son bureau officiel du coeur
de la capitale gay
est alors je reste ici je reste qui est
fille dans la rue bank covan je ne me
cache a
et je n'ai peur de personne au style qui
sculpte des poteries je resterai autant
qu'il le faudra pour gagner notre guerre
patriotique
un message adressé depuis l'emblématique
maison des chimères la résidence du
président depuis le début de la guerre
ces messages de volodymyr et l'inscrit
au coeur de kiev sont devenues un rituel
avec deux objectifs mobiliser les
ukrainiens et répondre à la
désinformation russe qui parle chaque
jour d'un président des faits ou en
fuite